مدينه دونيتسك الخاضعه لسيطره روسيا في
شرق اوكرانيا يؤكد رئيس بلديتها مقتل عده
مدنيين في هجمات صاروخيه نفذتها
اوكرانيا اوكرانيا التي تتلقى دعما ثابتا
من الغرب لكن المكاسب الميدانيه التي
حققتها في مواجهه روسيا ستكون في خطر في
حال لم يصادق الكونغرس الامريكي على
مساعدات جديده لاوكرانيا كما يقول وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي خلال مؤتمر صحفي مشترك
مع الامين لحلف شمال
الاطلسي حتى تستمر تلك المكاسب وكي نفعل
جميعا ما هو ضروري لضمان انتصار اوكرانيا
وفشل روسيا استراتيجيا من الاهميه بما كان
ان يصدق الكونغرس على طلب المساعده
الاضافيه الذي تقدم به الرئيس بايدن من
دونها كل ما حققه الاوكرانيين وما
ساعدناهم في تحقيقه سيكون في
خطر ما يقوله بلينكن شدد عليه كذلك الامين
العام للناتو الذي حل ضيف على واشنطن
والتقى كذلك بوزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد
اوستن الوضع في ساحه المعركه صعب لكن
حلفاء الناتو يقدمون دعما غير مسبوق
لاوكرانيا من المهم ان نستمر في القيام
بذلك ان دعمنا لاوكرانيا ليس صدقه بل انه
استثمار في امننا لان العالم سيصبح اكثر
خطوره لو انتصر الرئيس بوتين في
اوكرانيا الرئيس بوتين شارك مع نظيره
البيلاروسي الكساندر لوكاشينكو في اجتماع
مجلس دوله الاتحاد اشاد بالتعاون الثنائي
على الرغم مما وصفها بالضغوط الخارجيه غير
المسبوقه